ينضم الي الان عبر الهاتف وزير خارجيه
جنوب السودان ديني قداو اهلا بك سيدي
معالي الوزير هل لك ان تعطينا قراءتكم في
جنوب السودان لما يحدث في السودان وكنتم
بالاضافه الى مصر عرضتم الوساطه هل حصلتم
على رد
اولا شكرا جزيلا
على استضافه بصفه وزير
للخارجيه لجنوب السودان جنوب السودان ينظر
الى هذه الاوضاع التي تعيشها السودان بقلق
لان اي شيء قد يحدث في السودان سوف تكون
له تداعيات على المنطقه باوسعها
في البيت
قد يذكرنا بالاحداث التي عاشها السودان في
السابق
وكل من يساعده على وقف اطلاق النار من
خلال الوساطه او من خلال تامين ممرات
انسانيه للسودان سوف او تقديم المياه او
اي مؤن للمواطنين في الخرطوم سوف يكون
موضع تقدير
سيد دنق عندما تتحدث عن المساعدات لديكم
في السودان جنوب السودان 800 الف سوداني
هل انتم على استعداد لاستقبال المزيد هل
من استعدادات قائمه
لقد قمنا
باستقبال لمجموعه من السودانيين لسنوات
عده وامنا ماوى لهم
واننا سعداء لتامين ماوى وملجا لهم هنا
وحتى اللحظه يوجد لدينا
اكثر من 3000 لاجئ من سودان على مر
السنوات الخمسه الماضيه وهؤلاء اللاجئون
يعيشون
بكرامه في جنوب السودان
واننا مستعدون لاستقبال المزيد من
اللاجئين من السودان على استعداد لاستقبال
السودانيين اللاجئين ولكن ايضا كان هناك
في طرح تم الاعلان عنه من مصر بالشراكه
معكم
بعرض وساطه في السودان بين الطرفين هل
وصلكم اي رد هل لا زالت المساعي قائمه حتى
الان الدور الذي تقومون به
شكرا جزيلا
ان رئيسنا كان قد اجرى محادثه هاتفيه مع
اخيه الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي
وقد تطرق في
محادثتهما الى الوضع الحالي وكيف يمكن
لهما العمل
على حثه
الجنرال برهان وحميتي على وقف
قبول اطلاق النار والعوده لطاوله
المفاوضات
بحيث يتم
وقدي الخلافات بين الطرفين المتحاربين دون
احداث المزيد من ازهق حياه البشر
وبالمقاشر مع
الطرف او لا كجنوب السودان
نعم ان رئيس البلاد كان على اتصال مع كل
من الجنرلين
وخلال الايام القليله الماضيه على وجه
التحديد كان قد اهاب بالجنرال البرهان
والجنر الحميدي
للعمل
على وقف العمل العدائيه
كانت مقر لاتفاق جوبا للسلام هل تتوقعون
انه يمكن ان يكون لكم دور بهذا الاطار
فيما يتعلق بالحل للازمه الان من خلال
محادثه رئيس جنوب السودان سلفاكير مع
الجانبين هل تلمستم نوع من القبول لكونكم
وسيط محايد او لا
مقاربتنا في جنوب السودان
تنظر الى ان هذه المشكله هي مشكله سودانيه
وان السودان يجب ان ينبع من
السودانيين انفسهم في المقام الاول
وحالنا حال دول الاخرى المجاوره للسودان
فان او واجبنا فقط تقديمي العون والمساعده
ولكن الحل سوف ينبع من السودان انها ليست
ليست مساله الجنرال برهن او حميتي بل هناك
احزاب سياسيه اخرى التي يجلب عليها ان
تشارك في
صوغي الحل السياسي الذي سوف يزدل الستاره
على الحرب الحاليه الدائره في البلاد وسوف
يعمل على تامين السلام نعم جنوب السودان
سوف يبقى ملتزما
بصفته بلد مجاور للسودان في ايجاد الحل
الملائم للمشكله السودانيه لكن لكن حل
المشكله بصوره الاساسيه سوف تاتي من الشعب
السوداني ذاته
السوداني بحث ولكن بالمقابل هذا لا يمنع
ذكرت بالبدايه انه
تداعيات على
المنطقه ليس فقط علاقه الجوار ولكن خطوط
الانابيب فيما بينكم العلاقات الاقتصاديه
وغيرها يعني ذلك ان
السودان جنوب السودان
سيتاثر مباشره اليس كذلك
نعم هذا صحيح فاننا لا ننكر ان جنوب
السودان قد يتاثر من جراء الاوضاع الذي
تعيشه سودانه ولا سيما في ما يخص
خطوطي انابيب النفط التي تمتد بين البلدين
عبر بورسودان هذه مشكله كبيره قد تحمل
تداعيات كبيره لكن عندما نقول انها مشكله
سودانيه فهذا يعني بان كافه الاطراف داخل
السوداني يجب ان تساهم في حل المشكله
وانه يجب حلها في من قبل السودانيين لكننا
نستطيع كدوله المجاوره ان نساعده في اعطاء
في اعطاء
المشوره والتوجيه وان نكون
كمقر لتحقيق السلام بين الشعب السوداني
هل تعتقد انه السودان
ربما قابل لمزيد من التقسيم فيه او لا في
ظل التركيبه الداخليه بالسودان
[موسيقى]
نعمل
لا تصل الامور الى المزيد من المشاكل
وان القاده الحنيين في السودان سوف يعملان
على
تذليل الخلافات فيما بينهما
والتفادي اي شبح للتقسيم هل
تتابعون بقلق سحب الدول التيبلوماسيه
او انه هذا امر طبيعي بالنسبه لكم ويجب ان
يكون
هذه ليست بمساله طبيعيه فيما يخص الاوضاع
المساله تتعلق بسلامه الرعايه
الاجانب وعدد كبير منهم قد انتقل عبر حدود
جنوب السودان وهناك مواطنون اخرى
هناك مواطنون اخرون لقد انتقلوا ايضا عبر
بورسودان هذه ليست بمساله طبيعيه
ان يتم سحب كل هؤلاء الناس وان معظمهم قد
تركوا منازلهم واملاكهم فضلا عن موت البعض
الاخر
كان معنا على الهاتف وزير خارجيه جنوب
السودان شكرا جزيلا لك على هذه المشاركه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات